vi giuro su dio che più più andiamo
avanti in sto gioco e più mi inquieta la
partenza soprattutto neanche il gioco
insieme con la partenza del gioco
e vabbè ci sono sempre macchine che
corrono sono io no va bene hanno
aggiornato il suo si vede anche il
personaggio ma da chi storia non mi
chiama bellissima partenza così sono
maggior naturalmente così una figata
e vabbè se ciao cos'è sta roba è la
neighbor mica che figlio non aver che
giornalmente un fatto ma dai che storia
mica si fanno attendere gli
aggiornamenti sto gioco quando li
faranno orca [ __ ] noto con piacere
che ci sono un miliardo e mezzo distanze
c'è una specie di allora vediamo di che
si tratta solo per capire madonna che
grossista casa bene alla tedesca a
suonare il campanello permesso
fai un po meno casino quando ti muovi
minchia che sembra veramente un
rinoceronte in calore ok bel ragazzo
siamo possiamo capire che cosa sono sti
roma ho attivato qualcosa non negli anni
che cosa sia non lo voglio sapere questa
forte bloccata ma la sblocchiamo subito
a dà sul retro perfetto così almeno mi
sono sbloccato l'entrata sul retro
fantastico e quindi siamo madonna
qualcuno mi spiegate non vedo niente
magni 0 brom vedo nulla nel buio non c'è
una torcia qualcosa ragazzi c'è qualcosa
di veramente strano in tutto questo è
bellissimo perché mi piace una porta che
nel vuoto spiegami se riuscissi a
spaccare una fine capitana porca porca
son cagato in mano li facciamo ragazzi
non me ne ero poco accorto che poteva
arrivare il sistema quindi scusami se
apro la porta vuol dire che posso e
trecase entra in casa nell'armadio
cazzo e vabbè sei lento come mia nonna
zio porca eva e niente ragazzi ho
provato statica che non ha funzionato
però vabbè valeva la pena provare
allora c'è un oggetto ma quasi anche
questo va bene prendilo quindi ragazzi
adesso con questa in teoria in teoria
allora vediamo se riesco a spaccare un
vetro avete visto anche voi che c'era un
ombra solo io l'ho vista con la sedia no
però con le scatole di cartone si entra
mentre entrano porca [ __ ] ha avuto un
malore ragazzi allora era la sua
trappola per orsi un deficiente ok lo
trovo un armadio marmaglia che c'è una
gabbia ma cazzo
ok perfetto perfetto su su veloce non ci
voglio credere
[ __ ] perché ci deve essere sempre
qualcosa di chiuso ci ha bussato chi c'è
dietro sta porta oddio qualcuno di voi
sa come mai ho lanciato una torcia è
rimasta in piedi torcia flip challenge
la famigli prendere la torcia
innanzitutto come cazzo ma c'è veramente
un buco come l'high serrato tutto tranne
suo buco che però non entrava sì ce l'ha
fatta veramente come e come farla salire
qua open open cosa poi bova beh luca
so che ha mica tanto è mica tanto solo
che se riuscisse a chiudere magari prima
che arrivi il culo ma c'è un'altra
chiaro altre chiavi come se non bastasse
guarda niente di qua e messo sotto
chiuso per questo tutto chiuso anche
questa chiusa a questa aperta
oddio ma era la porta di fuori ce l'ho
fatta l'altro forte cos'è c'è una c'è
una chiave dietro il quadro fantastico e
come la dovrei prendere mi chiami serve
il magnete porca eva il magnete che
facessero e te lo infilo tutto quanto
posso posso bene corrie borsa sali aiuto
scherzo a ecco michela montorsi sisto
nozzolillo ok bene ho trovato il magnete
riesco stranissimo a posto ok non ci
voglio credere
2 no no no no no se veramente insulto la
famiglia
ma [ __ ] bene ho trovato la chiave
che cosa stai facendo zio ai ragazzi
allora proviamo un secondo di qua perché
non c'è ancora il tizio no perfetto
credo sia bene
apri una porta maledizione quanto tempo
su cagato restare manichino sedia no
divano
questo ha dei problemi cosa mi
rappresenta oddio devo tocca a era una
leva mista in qualche modo dicendo
chiedo per aggiungere con la porta
accatastando roba ho me lo sono
immaginato come ci arrivo la suv ma sono
cadute nelle scatole vediamo di scendere
per capire cosa c'é qua anche se credo i
porti più o meno no non mi porta per
niente dove pensavo dove cazzo siamo che
posso è questo cos'è sacrosanto gesù no
sono tutti posti mai visti prima noi là
di dove siamo ragazzi non ne ho la piu
pallida apri
ma cos'è a ok quello è lo scantinato
potrebbe sì ok lo riconosco bene quindi
siamo abbastanza in alto in teoria si è
chiusa
c'è una una gabbia c'è un fucile ce la
posso fare allora capiamo un attimo come
posso fare questa cosa la devo aprire la
gabbia come si apre la gabbia dove la
madonna un pass cioè è sempre in
discoteca mega a un'altra sedia da
togliere togliamo tutto voglio vedere se
porta dove penso è noah ok ok né no non
porta dove pensavo ma proprio per niente
volevi farmi uno scherzo de picenardi
falso nato prima io credo scherzavo se
in atto prima tu
ah ecco mi sembrava strano e mi metto
qua è però come l'attivo c'è un'idea
prova e non lo so
colmani nella mente cioè provera era
bella l'idea aspettavate un programmi
rar lo prima o poi faccia tirare la leva
mentre sono qui sopra ci dessero un modo
per forza vicino non è che mi dai una
mano a tirare la leva per favore grazie
ho capito ho capito fermi non posso
ancora farlo sapete perché chievo è
necessariamente prendere il fucile
l'aver agazzi concludo questa volta
l'episodio di nello nei bar andiamo
avanti poi nel prossimo comunque a parti
ma ancora veramente figo però spero
ragazzi che vi sia piaciuto corso è
diviso documento è un mi piace anche
vari social che come lei dottore nella
descrizione se gli chiedevi ci vediamo
un po se unito bella ragazzi